[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Right, so
today is going to be our first,
I believe, of two
problem sessions
covering dynamic programming.
I've learned dynamic
programming is
one of these interesting
parts of an algorithms class
where, somehow, the people
that are really good at it
are completely disjoint
with the people that
are good at all the other
parts of the algorithms class.
So for some of you guys,
that might be promising,
and for others, maybe
a little bit less so.
So maybe we'll spend just
a minute or two reviewing
the basic ideas we're going
to apply in these problems
because they'll follow, more
or less, the same template.
Although, of course,
as usual in 6.006,
we like to put some interesting
window dressing around it
so that it's not totally
obvious what you're doing.
And then we'll do a
bunch of sample problems.
Right.
So let's talk a little bit
about dynamic programming
and the basic idea here.
So, dynamic programming is kind
of a funny outlier in 6.006
in that--
for example, in the data
structures part of the course,
we learned, like, what--
now I'm struggling to
think of a data structure--
like a useful-- like trees
and arrays or whatever.
And these are actually
things that you can code.
if you look and
see if there are--
well, plausibly, it could
be an implementation
of a tree in there somewhere.
And so these are
useful algorithms
that you can maybe even
read the pseudocode.
And there's a universe
where you really
do translate that
pseudocode into something
inside of your laptop.
Dynamic programming is
a little bit less so.
This is more of a meta--
I don't know if you'd
call it a meta algorithm
or problem solving
approach or what,
but it's not like
you somehow say,
I'm going to apply the
dynamic programming
algorithm to this problem.
But rather, it's sort of this
big class of things that all
follow a similar template or
sort of approach to thinking
about problem solving, which
I think sort of explains why,
actually, in some sense, the
last couple of lectures that
you've seen-- and, I guess, if
I'm getting the time sequence
of our course right, the next
couple of years that you will
see--
and the problem
sessions actually
start to coincide in the sense
that when Erik was teaching
you guys dynamic programming,
how did he do it?
Well, he didn't
write down-- well,
he sort of wrote
down some template
for dynamic programming,
but then we just did
a bunch of sample problems.
And that's exactly what
we're going to do today.
So, somehow, all of
these things are just
going to converge in
this part of our course
because dynamic
programming, it's
really more of a way of life
than any particular algorithm.
And this is a
pattern that I think
you see a lot in
advanced algorithms.
Like, for example,
in my universe,
in numerical analysis, when you
talk about the ADMM algorithm,
it's actually a totally
useless algorithm.
What matters is applying
it to a particular problem.
And this is sort of, I think,
a more mature or grown up
way to think about
a lot of things
in algorithms, that pretty soon,
this sort of general purpose
stuff that's useful
all the time,
I think, it starts to
disperse a little bit in favor
of different patterns
and mechanisms
that you're used
to thinking about.
So there's my
10-second, sort of,
philosophical introduction
to what we're doing,
during which I've
managed to chase
this table across the room.
You know, I played--
I did college on the
west coast, and I
thought I was going
to be a music major.
And there was a piano
master class where
we forgot to put the
little clips on the wheels
and there was an
earthquake, and I just
thought I was really nervous
because the piano was literally
slipping away from me.
I can never think of that Chopin
nocturne in quite the same way.
But in any event, in
dynamic programming,
Erik laid out for you guys
a particular, sort of,
set of steps that are a useful
problem-solving approach
in the dynamic
programming universe.
In today's problem
session, I'm going
to try and help you guys
translate a little bit
from this template to what it
means to actually write code
to implement a dynamic
programming algorithm
because I think it's a little
easy to forget that here.
But, on the other
hand, on your homework,
when you're writing out
answers to algorithms problem,
it's perfectly fine to follow
this template even letter--
I guess-- literally letter
for letter and answer each
of these questions.
And then the remaining glue
that you need to actually write
the code is not
terribly exciting
from an algorithms
theory perspective.
So the basic idea
here is that there's
a lot of different problems
that can be written recursively,
in some sense.
Certainly, we've encountered
many of those in this course.
In fact, I think
the bias in the way
that we've presented
algorithms that
don't have to be recursive is to
write them in a recursive way.
And the point here is that
when you have a recursive call
and you repeat something,
you give the function
the same input
more than one time,
you might as well remember what
you got the last time you saw
that input, and
then you don't have
to do that computation again.
Really, in one sentence, I think
that's roughly the logic behind
all these dynamic
programming things.
So there's no reason to be
too redundant with lecture.
For just the
10-second overview, I
think that there's an example
which is simultaneously
good and misleading, which
is this Fibonacci sequence.
It's good in the sense that the
logic of dynamic programming
is really easy.
It's bad in that the runtime is
kind of weird to think about.
But remember, though,
your Fibonacci sequence
looks something like f of
k equals f of k minus 1
plus f of k minus 2.
And if you look at your, sort
of, recursive call tree here--
like, let's say that
I do k equals 4.
Then it's going to call--
my function f is going to have
to evaluate it at 3 and 2.
And then the 3 is going to
evaluate at 2 and 1, and so on.
And the thing to notice is
that when I call f of 4--
or, rather, f of 3 here, if
there were 3 somewhere else
in my tree, I get
the same number, so,
in particular, f
of 2 and f of 2.
Both of these are going
to take some amount
of algorithmic work, but
if just the first time
I see a 2 I have a little
piece of scratch paper
and I say, oh, any
time I see k equals
2, just return
this number rather
than doing recursive
calls, then, in effect,
if there's any subtree
underneath this thing,
I've just pruned
it from my tree.
And so that's the
basic logic here.
And that's basically
the paradigm
that's going on in this
SRTBOT acronym, which
is you first take your problem
and divide it into subproblems.
That is mysterious.
Why is this board moving?
Oh, there's a phone in my pocket
and I bumped against the wall.
I'm not used to this classroom.
Right.
Yeah.
So the first thing
you want to do
is to write my problem
as this sort of form.
Notice just that we've done
this a lot in this class,
we've written
things recursively.
The difference here is
the sort of argument
that goes into recursion
is typically, maybe,
a little simpler than putting
some giant data structure
inside of there or
something like that.
So, for instance,
merge sort, you
could write in this paradigm.
I guess we covered
that, but it's probably
not the most natural way
to think about merge sort.
Then we need to relate our
subproblems to each other.
So, for instance, in the
Fibonacci sequence problem,
I just gave you
the relation that--
what defines the problem.
Incidentally, this is, what,
a model for the reproduction
of rabbits, I
think, if I remember
reading the history of
the Fibonacci sequence.
And then, I think,
to me, the most--
not necessarily unnatural-- but
I think the thing that maybe is
hardest to translate to an
algorithm if you're thinking
about writing code is this--
oh, man, this is going
to be a problem--
this idea of topological order.
The basic idea here is that
if f of 1 depended on f of 2,
and f of 2 depended on f of
1, I'd be in a lot of trouble,
right, because somehow
my tree would never
converge, for one thing, if
I made these recursive calls
and I'd never be able
to memoize or, kind of,
remember a value when I move on.
Right?
And so the idea
here is that there's
some ordering of
my subproblem so
that I can build up a solution.
And there's, sort
of, two dual ways
to think about
why that's useful.
So in the memoization
universe, what do I do?
I just add an if statement
saying if I've already
evaluated f of k, return it.
That's perfectly fine.
The other thing I can do
is if I write my problems
in topological order,
then I can sort of
go in the reverse direction and
build up my memoization table.
So, for instance, for the
Fibonacci sequence problem,
I could do f of 1 and then f
of 2 and then f of 3 and f of 4
all the way until I get to the
k value that I actually wanted.
And those are just
duals of the same coin.
They're exactly
the same approach.
Although the
memoization version,
sometimes you can
prune out subproblems
that you didn't
actually need to solve.
So, for instance, maybe
this was f of k minus 7,
and so I can skip a few
indices in my array.
I don't think, typically, that
has a big effect on runtime
for the problems
that we've seen,
but it could, plausibly,
in some universal.
I'd have to think
about a problem
where that makes a difference.
Right.
And then I think the
BOT part of SRTBOT
is a little easier
to think about.
You have to make sure that
this recursion has a base case,
like when is this
thing going to stop.
That's exactly the same.
It's just any
recursive algorithm.
The O for original, I
think, is a little bit
retrofit to make
SRTBOT sound nice,
but I think the idea
here is that you
need to go back to
your original problem
and make sure that
it corresponds
to one of the function
calls that you've written
in all this complicated stuff.
Hopefully that's a
reasonable characterization.
And then, finally,
the t is more--
these are for describing
your algorithm.
The last one is
for analyzing it.
And, again, the
BOT part of SRTBOT
almost applies to anything we've
done in 6.006, like you should
always analyze your run time.
OK.
So, in any event, that's
my 10-minute version
of the last couple lectures
and, I think, more or less,
enough to get us started with
some sample problems here.
Sorry, I couldn't help it.
I like to teach things.
OK.
So, right.
So in our problem
session, we have
a few of the homework problems
from last year to go over.
If it makes you guys
feel any better,
I got myself all balled
up on one of them
last night while I was
preparing for today.
And I look forward to doing
that in front of all of you guys
now.
Right.
So, I'm afraid of this, so I'm
going to go to the next board.
OK.
So in our first
problem, Sunny studies--
this was-- somehow,
the cute naming
conventions we have in 6.006
got really meta in this problem,
because there's a problem
about Tim the Beaver.
But, as we all know,
Tim is MIT backwards,
so he happens to fit
into this goofy game
that Jason likes to play in
writing homework problems.
Anyway, but it's
also the MIT mascot.
Anyway, I got very excited.
Right.
So what's going on
in this problem?
So Tim the Beaver has kind
of an interesting-- you know,
mathematics, I think you would
call this a martingale if you
flip the coin a little bit
when he solve this problem.
But luckily, Tim the Beaver is
a deterministic kind of a guy.
And he looks at the
weather outside,
and if it's a temperature
t-- apparently,
Tim the Beaver is
OK with boiling.
The higher the temperature,
the happier Tim gets.
So this is a first derivative
kind of a phenomenon.
In particular, on a given day,
if I have a temperature t,
Tim the Beaver has
two things that he
can do to change his mood.
Apparently, Tim the Beaver's
mood never stays fixed.
It always goes up and down.
In particular, he can either
go outside, in which case
the happiness increases by
t, OK, or he can stay inside,
in which case his
happiness decreases by t.
OK.
So every day, Tim the
Beaver, he wakes up he--
I really want to say that
he checks for his shadow,
but that's a gopher, right?
i any event, he wakes up in the
morning, he checks the weather,
and he makes the
determination does
he want to go outside or not.
And if he goes outside,
he gets happier
by an amount that's
equal to the temperature.
If he stays inside, he gets
less happy by an amount that's
equal to the temperature.
By the way, I think our
solution is perfectly fine
if temperatures are negative
here, in which case,
I guess, everything
would flip intuitively.
But there's no reason to
get too hung up on that.
But, of course,
there's a twist here.
So Tim, as with many of you,
has n days until his final exam.
And he's worried about studying.
Yeah?
So, in particular, he
never wants to go--
he's come up with
a personal resolve
to never go outside more
than two days in a row.
Yeah?
So, right.
And so the question is--
right, because that way
he has to stay inside
and study at least one
out of every three-ish days.
OK.
So the question is how can
Tim maximize his happiness.
Incidentally, in
machine learning,
sometimes they call
that minimizing regret,
which I always found
to be a very sad way
to think about algorithms when
there's a totally dual version.
But Tim's an optimistic guy.
He wants to maximize his
happiness subject to this
constraint that he cannot go
outside more than two days
in a row.
Right?
So if I go out on
Monday and Tuesday,
I have to stay
inside on Wednesday.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I think there's
no effect to his happiness
when he stays in.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: There's
no effect to his happiness
when he stays in.
AUDIENCE: At least,
that's [INAUDIBLE]..
JUSTIN SOLOMON: No, it says
with a decrease in happiness
when t-- oh, when t is negative.
That's not actually going to
affect our problem at all.
AUDIENCE: It's not
going to affect it.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Sure,
yeah, I can fix this live.
This is what happens when
I do the problem myself
before looking at the answer
and then don't check it closely.
Fine.
So let's change that.
I like this problem better,
somehow, psychologically.
But that's OK.
Right.
So, Jason correctly points
out that if you actually
read the problem, what's asked
there is slightly different,
that when he goes outside,
his happiness increases by t.
If he stays inside, his
happiness does nothing.
Right?
So it stays the same.
My apologies, so Tim the Beaver
is a particularly optimistic
beaver.
His happiness can
only increase in time,
assuming he lives in a climate
with positive temperatures.
OK.
I think I've got it right now.
Cool.
We'll see if I
can still do this.
Yeah, I think basically
nothing changes.
OK, that's great.
All right.
We're going to do it.
OK.
Right, so the question is
how do we solve this problem.
And thankfully, I think we
put the easiest problem first.
And, in particular, if we're
following our SRTBOT paradigm
here, somehow there's a
set of subproblems that
are staring us in the face.
That's the word I'm looking for.
In particular,
well, there's sort
of only one index in
our problem, which
is what day it is.
So the obvious thing
to do would be to say,
can we figure out
the maximum amount
of happiness for days,
say, i to the last day?
By the way, if I do that,
I'm using the prefix version
of my problem--
ah, suffix version
of my problem.
I could also do it the opposite
way and work from the end
back in.
Maybe if we have time
all the way at end,
we'll do the second one.
But it doesn't really matter.
OK.
So, in particular, just to
add a little bit of notation,
let's say that t of i is equal
to the temperature on day i.
OK.
And now we're going to
make a new thing, which
is going to be the actual
variable we want to compute.
This is going to be x to
i, which, we'll write,
is the maximum happiness that
you can achieve if you only
consider the calendar from day
i to day n, I guess inclusive.
OK.
Incidentally, just
for convenience,
we'll assume that
x i is equal to 0
if I go past the end of
my array, which I think
is, kind of, a, typical thing to
do in these type DP algorithms.
OK.
So the question is can
we actually come up
with a recursive
algorithm that computes
x i using this nice, sort
of, typologically acyclic way
of thinking about our problem.
The answer is obviously yes,
or I wouldn't be here today.
And so in the absence
of a smarter idea,
let's just do the Toucan
Sam approach here and follow
our nose and see if we can
just write our problem in terms
of other ones.
So, in general, let's
say that Tim the Beaver
wakes up on day i.
He has, basically, two decisions
that he can make, right?
He can either stay inside
or he can not stay inside.
He can go outside, right?
So let's just basically
handle these three cases.
So in case, one he stays inside.
Well, now what happens
to his happiness?
Well, according to
my revised version
of this problem, nothing, so,
in particular, what do we know?
Well, if he stays
inside, then he has--
any decision he can make
tomorrow, it doesn't matter.
He can go inside,
he can go outside,
whatever, because by
having stayed inside,
he's earned himself two
free days of going outside
if he wants.
Right?
So, in particular, in this
case, we can convince ourselves
that this is true, I think.
Yes, so, in other words, while
he gets no utility for today,
he wakes up tomorrow and he
can make whatever decision
he wants.
OK.
The second thing he
can do is go out.
This is where things
get a little tricky.
Right?
Can I just do, like, take t
i and add it to x i plus 1?
What goes wrong?
AUDIENCE: You go
out three days--
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Maybe you go
out three days in a row, right?
Somehow, you have to
remember that, right?
And so that's where things are
a little bit of a headache,
that, in particular, if I
go out today and tomorrow,
I can't go out the
day after that.
And somehow, if we just
dealt with this one case
as t i plus x i plus 1,
we wouldn't remember that.
And that's a problem.
So, instead, what we
can do is think of there
being two subcases, right?
So what we're going to assume
is that not only does he
go out today, but that he's
free to go out tomorrow.
And we're going to make
that recursive assumption
as we move down our array.
So if we do that, well, now
we have case a and case b.
So in case a, he goes out
today and he stays in tomorrow.
Yeah.
OK.
So what happens in
this case, well--
by the way, I'm using this
kind of weird arrow notation.
I don't know if
this is good or not,
but, essentially,
the point is that I'm
keeping track of cases,
and then eventually I'm
going to want to
have to take the max
overall of these things.
So I don't like the equal
sign because somehow that's
a little misleading.
Right.
So in that case, well,
he gets the utility
of having gone out today.
Tomorrow he stays
in, which means
that the day after tomorrow
he can do whatever the heck
he wants.
He has free reign.
So I can write that using
this recursive call.
OK.
Similarly-- right.
I'm getting the hang of this.
Sorry, this is way too
entertaining for me.
I can play with
this board all day.
OK.
So in case 2b, he goes out
today and he goes out tomorrow.
OK?
So--
AUDIENCE: He's a party animal.
JUSTIN SOLOMON:
He's a party animal.
He is an animal and
he's going out a lot.
Right, so in that
case, what happens?
Well, he gets that.
He gets today's utility.
He gets tomorrow's utility.
The day after, he
has to stay in,
so we might as well skip it.
And then he can do whatever
he wants the day after that.
OK?
So if we go back, I
guess, technically, we
should revise our
definition of x a tiny bit,
that it's not the maximum
of happiness-- well,
we can convince ourselves
that it's the same thing.
But really, it's not the maximum
happiness for day i through n.
It's the maximum
happiness for day
i through n under the
assumption that he has
permission to go out on day i.
Right?
And that's really
what's going on
in our recursive
set of calls here.
OK.
So does our recursion
make sense here?
Cool.
All right.
So let's see here.
So if we're following
our SRTBOT--
I keep reviewing papers that
use the word paradigm a lot,
so I feel like I should do that.
So what is t?
It's the topological order.
Notice that x i only
depends on larger i's.
So in terms of our
topological order,
the dependence graph
is really simple.
It's just a line,
so remember that you
can think about
topological order
or you can think about
being acyclic graph.
Those are equivalent.
We covered that in this course.
I kind of like thinking
about acyclic graphs.
So x1 depends on x2 depends
on x3 depends on x4.
That graph has no
cycles, so we're good.
Right.
So next we have to
come up with our base
case for our recursion.
Notice that the way I have
chosen to solve this problem
is by calling future
indices, which
means that my base case
sits at the end of my array
because that's sort of like the
lowest down on the recursion
train.
The recursion chain is
what I was going for,
but I kind of like the
recursion train better.
In particular, on day n--
well, if he has permission
to go out on day n,
he can do one of two things.
He can either go out or not.
It doesn't matter, right?
So, in particular, we can
say that that's the max of 0
or t of n.
Remember, I didn't tell
you that temperatures
have to be positive.
Maybe he's a Celsius
kind of a beaver.
OK.
Right.
And then in addition to the--
for convenience,
notice that, like,
there's a universe where I
look beyond the end of my array
in my recursive call here, so
I should probably think about
a few extra x's.
Obviously, the utility of going
out on a day that doesn't exist
is 0.
So we can say that x n plus
1 equals x n plus 2 equals 0.
OK.
I've managed to use way
too much space for one
simple algorithms problem.
OK.
Yeah?
I get credit for that?
OK.
Right.
So now we need to
do the o and the t.
So what's our original problem?
Well, remember that he wants to
maximize his happiness starting
on day one, so our original
problem is just x of 1,
or is it?
So, remember that
Tim the Beaver--
your instructor is
very sloppy when
it comes to actually
reading the problems,
as you saw at the beginning.
A second mistake for which
I would have personally
lost points were I to solve
this problem on my homework
is that it didn't ask for just
the maximum amount of happiness
that Tim could achieve--
that's not very practical
for your everyday beaver--
but rather, he wants to
know the actual plan.
He wants to know what days he
can go out and what days he
can't.
Yeah?
And I haven't actually told
you how to do that, right?
I've only told
you how to compute
x, which is just the
maximum amount of happiness.
If I were you guys,
I think this is
a perfectly reasonable
simplification that's
like a warm up problem to solve.
In fact, I would argue it's
less of a warm up and more
the crux of the problem--
and then going back
and making sure
you can convince yourself
that you could actually
reconstruct the solution.
My way of solving this
was ever so slightly
different from the
one in the problem,
but they're equivalent,
which is to say
I can make a second array--
I won't write it down,
because I'm slow at writing--
that just says on every day,
whether I took option 1, option
2a, or option 2b.
And now I can reconstruct
my plan very easily, right?
So I look at x1, if I took
option 1, then I stay in
and I look at day two.
If I took option 2a, then I
can label today, tomorrow,
and the day after.
Oh, wait-- yeah, that's right.
I can label today's choice,
tomorrow's choice, the day's
after choice, and then
look three days later
and recurse that way.
Option b is kind of similar.
So a reasonable way to
reconstruct the actual set
of what days you go out
and what days you go in
is just to remember, as you do
your memoization or whatever,
whether you did
option 1, 2a, or 2b.
And then it's pretty easy
to reconstruct from there.
Maybe I'll let you guys
convince yourselves
of that at home or
in the last 8 seconds
if you happen to be the two
audience members that I have.
And then, finally, we
need to do our time thing.
And most of the
time arguments here
follow more or less
the same pattern,
which is you count the
number of subproblems
and the time per subproblem,
you multiply those two things
together, and you
get your runtime.
We're going to
see in one problem
on this problem set that's
not quite right because we
have to account for
some precomputation.
But in this case, it is.
Right, so let's see, what
are our subproblems here?
Well, essentially-- I guess
I didn't actually say it,
but you have to take the
max of these three values.
This is the max of
three expressions which
have a constant number
of plus signs and lookups
and memory and all
that good stuff.
So each subproblem
takes order one time.
How many problems are there?
Well, there's, I
guess, n plus 2 max,
if you want to be
conservative about it.
So, in particular, there's
order n subproblems, right?
So all I have to do is multiply
these two things together,
and my algorithm
takes order n time.
And that's our solution
to problem number one.
Any questions so far?
Yes?
Uh-oh.
AUDIENCE: When I was thinking
about the problem beforehand,
I was wondering could
you use base cases--
right now, we have two
different kinds of base case,
a base case for x of n and a
base case for things after.
Can I remove the first
one and add an x of n
plus 3 equals 0 as well?
What would that do?
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Could
I remove the first one
and add an x of n plus 3?
Yeah, I guess that's fine.
I'm sorry, that's not a
particularly helpful answer
for the people
watching on video.
My answer to this question
you can't hear is yes.
So the question, to repeat,
was this base case was somehow
kind of complicated-looking.
To be fair, it's
the one that I was
given in [INAUDIBLE]
assignment, but that's OK.
But the question was is
this truly necessary.
In particular, can I
get rid of the x n case
and instead add a third
day past the end of time,
which also has value 0?
And if you, kind of, look at
that plus case b, I think--
or rather, case a--
think you can convince--
well, case a and b,
for that matter-- you can
convince yourselves that these
are equivalent, right?
That's absolutely right.
So I could add a third day after
the end of this thing, which
also has value 0.
Or, by the way, I could just
say in my code if n is--
if i is bigger than n, return 0.
That's the same thing.
Yeah, and then I
guess I don't have
to worry about that x n case.
Yeah, these are the same.
To each their own.
Fabulous question.
Any others that I can
answer while we're at it?
Cool.
All right.
So that's problem one.
Writing too big-- I don't
like this big chalk, you know.
OK.
So problem two is the
one that got me all hot
and bothered yesterday.
So let's see if we do any
better in front of people,
because that's usually
the best way to improve
a problem solving skill.
Right.
So in problem two,
which, annoyingly,
is also probably the
most practical problem
on this problem set.
Essentially, you have a--
I suppose I should
write some stuff down.
So in problem--
I used the wrong side--
two, you have an
operating system Menix--
whatever-- which is--
apparently, it's very simple.
AUDIENCE: Menix, Unix.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Oh, I get it.
[LAUGHS] It doesn't
mean I have to like it.
Right.
[LAUGHS] So, in
Menix, apparently,
the only thing that my
operating system can do
is compute edit
distance between files.
And it wants to
do so efficiently.
So we have that a file
is a sequence of strings.
And I believe we
say their length is
less than or equal to k.
That's going to come into
play a little bit later.
And the strings are
basically just lines
of the different files.
So there's three different
ways that we can change a file.
So here are the
changes we can do.
Change number 1
is to add a line.
Change number 2 is
to remove a line.
And change number 3 is to swap.
But a caveat for this
interesting model
of what's cheap and what's
not is that, apparently,
swapping two lines is cheap
because they exist in memory.
Like, maybe I'm, I don't
know, using a linked
list or something
to store files,
and so swapping two
pointers isn't so bad.
But inserting and
removing a line
is hard because, I don't know,
memory allocation is expensive,
like Menix is actually
operating on clay tablets.
And I can chop my clay
tablets into different slices
and just pick them up and
swap them, and that's fine,
but if I want to add
a line in my file,
I have to go to the Tigris and
Euphrates and pull out the--
or whatever it was,
the Eugris and the
Tiphrates-- and
pull out a stone.
It's a lot of work to make
a new line or to dispose.
So these are expensive
and this is cheap.
And so the question
that I'm trying to sa--
that I'm trying to say and that
the problem is trying to ask
is that you are given files
A and B with n lines each.
We want to know what the minimum
number of non-swap operations
it'll take, and
so, in other words,
the minimum number of time for
you to add and remove lines
to transform A into B,
essentially, with low cost.
And, in fact, just to be nice--
I think it's actually kind of a
critical hint in this problem--
we give you the runtime.
And I'm going to, kind of,
ignore it in my answer,
notice that I did something
wrong, and then go back
and fix it.
This is different from the
way the answer is written,
where god came in and said,
like, oh, we observe that we're
probably going to
need this thing,
so we're going to go
ahead and do it here.
I think that's, maybe, not
representative of the logic
here.
Right, so the runtime here
is k n plus n squared.
The first thing to note
is there is a k here.
Yeah, and so someday we're going
to have to compare strings,
because that's what k is.
And I think that's
the hint that's
implicit in this problem.
It's easy to miss.
And so, indeed, what
we're going to notice
is we're going to
look at our solution
and say, well, wait a second, if
we didn't incur a factor of k,
we must have done
something wrong.
And, indeed, that's
going to be the case,
but it's only a minor
fix to change it.
AUDIENCE: There's another
important distinction
on this [INAUDIBLE].
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Oh, I'm sorry.
Yeah, right, when I swap things,
they have to be adjacent.
I can't write at the
bottom of the board.
That's supposed to be a, d,
j, for those watching at home.
But they have to
be-- you can only
swap lines that are
adjacent, as they
appear in their original file.
I'll say it out loud rather than
try and write it because you
it's going to take the rest
of the lecture to do that.
OK, any other things
I've forgotten?
There's a high likelihood.
I'm bad at this.
OK.
So this one was annoying.
And it's not actually annoying.
It's actually a relatively easy
instance of a very well-known
dynamic program plus a tiny
bit of additional stuff, which
is called edit distance.
In fact, I think if you guys
are looking for intuition
on this problem,
you might google
that one first as, sort of, a--
what was that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Oh, in fact
you're doing a recitation.
Oh, that's why it's not
totally unreasonable to come
up with the answer
here, even better.
But even if you
hadn't, you know,
this is just another
dynamic programming problem
that's just a little
bit more annoying
than your average dynamic
programming problem.
Now, the solution written
out in the course notes
works from, sort of, the
last line of the file
downward, in some sense--
upward, whatever.
I, like, literally lost
two hours of my life
trying to think about
editing files from the end up
and just getting myself
all upset and confused.
So here, I'm going to attempt
to do it in the other direction
and probably introduce a bunch
of mistakes in the process.
So what do we do in
dynamic programming
if we don't know
what else to do?
We do sort stuff, SRTBOT.
And so let's do that here.
So, in particular, what
are our subproblems?
This is a little bit funky.
So actually, even before
we do the S of SRTBOT,
let's think about our
problem a little bit.
Let's think about
what it actually
means to edit a
file because this
is what helped me think
about the right answer
here, which is to
say, you know--
so what's going on?
I have, like, two documents.
This is document A. This is
document B. Each one of them
is composed of a bunch of lines.
And I'm basically
trying to turn A into B.
And the only thing I can
do is scroll out of line,
insert, just hit the Enter
key, or do a third thing
where I kind of like
swap two things that
are adjacent to one another.
That is the only thing I can do.
And the way I like to
think about this problem--
there's kind of
an annoyance here,
which I think is a
typical annoyance
in dynamic programming
problems, which
is that the order of operations
suggests that this problem is
a lot, combinatorially, more
difficult than it is, because,
like--
OK, let's think about how I
actually edit documents-- like,
I spend 2/3 of my day editing
bad grad student writing--
is like I'm jumping all over the
place between different lines.
Like, first I delete
this line, then
maybe I go to the
bottom of my document
and delete some other one.
That would be a big problem
from a dynamic programming
perspective.
I can't jump all
over my document,
because keeping track of
that whole edit history
is going to be somehow
combinatorially ginormous.
Right?
I'm not the Track Changes
button in Microsoft Word.
I want the minimum
number of changes.
And if I have to recurse
over all possible edits
to every single
line in any order,
that's an awful
lot of factorials
and 2 to the n's floating around
that I don't want to have.
Right?
And so that's the sort of
crux of the challenge here,
is to organize my approach
to editing these files
in a way that doesn't
require me to have
to do this sort of combinatorial
jumping all over the place.
And I think it's also the
one where there's a sort of--
like I know Jerry
Caine at Stanford talks
a lot about the
recursive leap of faith.
Like, somehow
dividing your problem
into organized
subproblems, that's
really where the
challenge lives here.
So if I were a more
organized PhD advisor,
the way that I would edit
a file, or a clay tablet,
I guess, in this case,
would be linearly,
that I might as well
do whatever the heck
I'm going to do to line one
before I move on the line two.
And at the end of the
day, even if I did stuff
in a different order,
you can convince yourself
that I could always
order it in such a way
that all the edits that
I do to the first line,
kind of, happen before
lines later in the document,
with the possible exception
of this swap thing.
But we'll see that
somehow doesn't matter.
And, moreover, if
I do an edit, I
might as well do the edit to
make things better, right?
There's no reason to start
willy-nilly inserting
and removing lines.
I might as well always do an
operation that improves stuff.
And so thinking about that
sort of logic leads me--
ta-da-- to a particular
way that I might write down
my S, my some
problems here, which
is to say that I'm going to
think about editing my document
line by line.
So, in other words, once
I've dealt with line one,
meaning that I found
some way to mess with it
and make it match line
one of the other guy,
I'm just going to
think about removing it
and then think about the
rest of the document.
You start saying, aha, that
sentence sounds like recursion.
And that's right.
That's how we're going
to solve this problem.
OK?
So, in particular, here's
going to be our thing.
I'm going to do a slightly
different one in the solution--
so you guys should
all be vigilant--
which is I'm going to write x ij
to be the min work to convert.
I'm not a Python programmer,
but hopefully I got this right.
i colon is going to
be everything from i
to the end of the file.
So in other words, this is the
suffix version of our problem--
and into B j colon, like that.
OK.
So, in other words,
I have a little--
it's kind of like a video--
like, think about Tetris.
Once you get that
full line of blocks,
you can just throw that
line of blocks away
and the whole video
game moves down.
There's somehow
something very similar
going on here, which
is the second I've
managed to get a match
for line one of document
into line one of
the next document,
I'm just going to throw
it away and pretend
like I have two documents
with one less line in them.
Now, the thing that got
me all hung up last night,
my original problem assumes
that both of my documents
have the same length.
But here, I'm not making
that assumption, right?
And, essentially, what
we're going to figure out
is that that actually
doesn't matter a whole lot,
that if I end up with one
document of length k--
well, I shouldn't use k--
one document of length l and
another document of length 0,
what's the amount of work
that I should do to convert?
Well, l, because my only choice
is to insert a bunch of lines
in one document, by the way,
or delete a bunch of lines
from the other.
Those are dual to one another.
They're exactly the same.
I'm philosophizing a lot because
I'm also convincing myself
that my answer is
OK in the process.
OK.
So this is going to be
our set subproblems.
And now we have to
do the r, right?
We have to relate, something
we struggle with in the math
department sometimes.
And, essentially, the way
that I went about this
is to just do a
billion different cases
of all the possible edits that
I could do to line i and line j.
And that's perfectly
fine in this problem.
I think the problem
is a little slick.
And the way that they're
written the solution,
they've convinced themselves
that some things are
equivalent to others
and removed them.
But you don't have to.
As long as there's
a constant number
of cases, your golden Ponyboy.
So, in particular, let's
think about some cases.
So first of all, if line i
matches line j of my document--
remember that it's
not really line j.
It's like making a
document that just
happens to start at line j.
It's like taking scissors.
Well, then I can match
them with zero-cost
because the beginnings
are in the same place.
And I can move my
Tetris came down one,
and that's perfectly fine.
So case one, I think,
is the easiest one,
which is if A i equals
B j, then I can just
remove that line
from both documents
and move forward,
in which case--
I'll use my same
goofy notation--
I'm going to get that x ij.
Well, I'm going to
just increment i and j
and keep going, like that.
Cool?
So what's something
else I could do?
I could delete a line.
Yeah, so what happens--
OK.
So case two is
delete A i, right?
That's a different thing
I can do the line i.
Well, now what do I have to do?
I have a document on
the left-hand side,
which is 1 line shorter.
And on the right-hand
side, nothing changed.
But deleting a line
cost me a dollar.
So, in particular,
I have that x ij.
Well, what happens?
Well, I got rid of one
line, but I had to pay.
OK.
Let's think about
some other things.
You could delete B j.
This case actually
isn't in the solution
because it turns out
to be unnecessary.
AUDIENCE: Well, we're
only allowed to edit A.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Oh, I'm
only allowed to edit A?
Oh, in that case, I
don't have to delete B j.
I really didn't read these
problems very closely.
That's my bad.
This would have
made it much easier.
I really should
read these things.
Cool, so that eliminates half
of the cases on my notes.
Fabulous.
Incidentally, you could do these
things on the other direction
and it really wouldn't change
this problem a whole lot.
Sorry, you know, I
have this bad habit
when I'm reading research papers
of reading the research paper I
wanted to be there
instead of the one
that's actually on the paper.
And, somehow, it's very
similar phenomenon here.
OK.
Right.
So, great.
So I can only edit
document A, which
makes this probably easier
than what I was worried about.
Fabulous.
In that case-- ah, bananas.
With our third case
here, well, let's see,
I could also insert a line.
Let's see.
So what ends up happening there?
So I can only edit document A?
So that makes my cases
different than the ones
I wrote down on my notes.
Sorry.
OK.
So if I insert--
let's do this live.
Yeah, OK, so if I
insert a line at line i,
I might as well
make it match B j.
There's no reason not to.
Right?
I might as well kill off one
element of B while I'm at it.
Yeah?
So if I do that, what
ends up happening?
Well, I still have
to match line i.
I've just, kind of, moved
it lower in my file.
But I've, in essence,
killed one line in file B
by making it match this
new line that I inserted.
In my notes, because I
thought I could edit B,
I said, OK, I can just
delete the line in B instead.
And somehow, logically, that's
a little easier to think about.
But these are exactly
dual to one another.
So, in that case, I have x ij.
Well, I still have
to deal with A i.
I haven't gotten rid of it.
But I've matched line j.
So I paid $1 for
inserting a line.
And now I have that
because I've gotten rid
of a line in the other file.
If I stopped here, by the way,
I would have it at a distance.
But, unfortunately for me,
I have one additional case,
which is mild irritant, as they
say, which is that I can swap.
First of all, can I always swap?
I mean, I can, but
if I swap two lines
and they still don't match the
lines on the right-hand side,
I'm kind of hosed, right,
because you can convince
yourself that in
the next step, I'm
going to have to delete
something anyway.
Swapping was free.
If I swap and delete, that's
the same thing as just deleting,
so it doesn't really matter.
So, in particular,
what that means
is I might as well only
check the swap if it actually
helps me.
Yeah?
So, in other words,
if I have A--
now you have to be a little bit
careful because I'm swapping.
So if the next guy in A
equals B, the current guy in B
and the current guy in A
equals the next guy in B. Well,
now I can swap this guy and
kill off two lines in my files
while I'm at it, right?
So, in this case,
I get that X ij.
Well, swapping doesn't
cost me anything,
and I killed off two things.
So that's the recursion.
So if I were to write
this out on my homework,
what should I do?
Well, I shouldn't-- I mean,
probably if you use this error
notation, I don't think
it would be a big deal.
But really, you
should add a line
at the bottom saying
that I can choose
to do any of these things.
So really, my
recursive call is x
ij gets the min
of all of these 1,
2, 3, 4 expressions
that I've written here.
OK.
AUDIENCE: What if you have
the first condition but not
the second one?
JUSTIN SOLOMON: What if I have
the first condition but not
the second one?
Ah, so that's a great question.
Yeah, so the question
was like, OK, well,
what if I can match the next
line but not the current one.
Well, there's two different
things you could do.
You could either make
another case for that.
That's perfectly fine.
In fact, you could do that.
You could do that I matched
the second condition, not
the first one, whatever.
You can just enumerate
as many things
you want as long
as they're all true
and there's a constant number.
Alternatively, you
can convince yourself
that actually is unnecessary
here because a different--
so that's like swapping.
But then one of those two
lines is still a mismatch,
so you're going to have
to delete something
in the next step.
So you might as well just
delete first, rather than
swap and then delete.
And so that's why that
case isn't necessary.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
in the first case.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Exactly.
Exactly.
So if you swapped and you
killed a line, then, in effect,
I think it's a combination
of case 1 and case 2
here, if you, kind of,
expand your recursion out.
But if you're having
trouble convincing yourself
of that, that's fine,
just add a case here.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
I'm going to ask quickly because
this problem makes me nervous.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Sure.
OK.
In the worst case, if
we've done something wrong,
you can certainly add
another case here.
I'll think about it at home.
OK.
So since I've managed
to pontificate too long,
let's keep moving here.
AUDIENCE: Can we swap them
if they [INAUDIBLE] match?
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Oh,
you know, the problem
is it might have been--
AUDIENCE: --used
in the final file.
So if you can make swap one
match one of them and not
the other, then that's not OK.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Yeah, because
at the end of the day,
the files have to agree.
Like, you have to match B to A.
AUDIENCE: Swap and
delete is cheaper
than doing two deletes
and two inserts.
AUDIENCE: No, no, no,
but the swap and delete
is illegal because you
have to use both ones.
That's a condition
in the pocket.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Oh, I'm sorry.
That's a better answer.
So Jason points out
that if I swap, then
I can't delete it because the
way the problem is written.
So that effectively
removes this case.
Otherwise, I think--
I guess Erik is--
AUDIENCE: Actually, there are
two important conditions--
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Oh, sorry.
I've managed to
totally botch this,
which is totally unsurprising.
Yeah.
So I think the problem also
states that if you swap,
the swap has to be useful.
And that's why this
additional case
that Erik is asking about
where you swap and then you
match one line but not
the other is unnecessary.
You might be able to relax that
by just adding a case here,
but since the problem
doesn't ask it,
I'm not going to think about.
OK.
Right.
So, under all the
assumptions of this problem
that I didn't read but are
very important to solving
this problem
correctly, I believe
we really have written
down all of our cases here.
OK.
So let's continue with
our SRTBOT paradigm.
So now we have all
of our recursion.
The topological order here is a
little bit trickier than normal
because now you've got
a two-dimensional array,
but it follows a pattern
that's pretty typical here,
which is that x ij only
depends on other x ij's
with higher i plus j.
So I think about my
graph of subproblems.
If I wrote this in a 2D
matrix, it always, kind of,
points down and to
the right, maybe,
which is what's
making it acyclic.
This is a very typical
pattern in these sort
of two-dimensional dynamic
programming problem.
All right.
So let's see here, SRTBOT.
So we need our base case.
This isn't too bad
because, essentially,
when you have boring
documents, they're
very easy to match
to one another.
So, in particular, for any
i, if I'm at line n plus 1--
in other words, I have a blank
document that I'm matching
to document i--
well, how much work
do I have to do?
You have to be a
little bit careful.
This is where the suffix version
of this problem is a little bit
more annoying than
the prefix one--
or have I managed to swap
those backward again--
that, in particular, the
remaining number of lines
looks like n plus
1 minus i, which is
different than in the problem.
It's just i because
they're working
in the other direction--
in the solution, rather.
And similarly, you need a second
case for those two here, right?
So you have x n plus 1 j is
going to be n plus 1 minus j.
Cool.
OK.
So we're going to
continue with SRTBOT here.
So what is our original case?
Kind of by definition
it's x 1, 1 or 0 0,
depending on how you index.
And then, finally,
what's our runtime?
Well, let's see, there's n
plus 1 squared subproblems,
and, of course, that's
equal to order n squared.
The subproblems are just
a constant amount of work,
so they're each
with constant work.
So our entire runtime
is order n squared.
And hopefully by watching me
be confused in front of you
and think through
this problem, you too
will see how the problem
solving procedure
can happen in your own
disorganized brains.
OK.
So that concludes our
treatment of this problem here.
That, I think, is
the hardest one.
So the other two, thankfully,
are much easier to think about,
I thought.
But I never liked edit distance.
I remember seeing that and
undergrad algorithms getting
confused.
OK.
So the next problem, problem 3
here, deals with Saggy Mimsin.
And she has a bunch
of block, and she
wants to stack them on top
of each other, as one does.
And as a young
structural engineer,
she has a few criteria
on her problem.
Let me go to the right
page in my notes here.
Right.
So this is problem 3.
So we have that block bi has
size that looks like width wi
by height hi by length li.
I remember getting confused
in elementary school
about the difference between
width and length all the time.
To me, those always
sounded the same.
But it doesn't really
matter, because she's
happy to rotate her cubes
any way that she pleases.
There's a key detail which I
did remember to actually read
in this problem, which is
that she has at least three
of each type, where type
here means that I can permute
these three numbers
any way that I
want because that's the same
as just rotating a block.
But any time she has one
block that's like 1 by 2 by 3,
she has at least two more
in her bag somewhere.
OK.
APPLE WATCH: It's 6.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Oh, 1 times
2 times 3 is equal to 6.
Thank you, Apple Watch.
OK.
So that's odd.
So she can orient
her block any way
that she wants, meaning she
can rotate it in any fashion
that she'd like.
And so what we're trying
to do, what we want
is the max height where
she's stacking her n blocks.
I suppose I should
say they're n blocks.
So she wants the max height
that she can achieve.
But just to be kind of
annoying, or because, again,
she's very concerned with
structural stability--
she lives in an
earthquake zone--
she would like
with the condition
that each block is strictly
supported on the block
beneath it.
Right?
So in other words, if this
is the base of one block,
then the next block that's
stacked on top of it
has to be strictly contained
within the block below it.
Right?
So does the problem make sense?
Have I omitted any
critical details?
I don't think I have this time.
This one's a little easier.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Oh, yeah.
And she can't do anything crazy.
She can't do a weird,
like, balance it
on this edge kind
of thing, which--
Erik is absolutely right--
could actually give her a taller
tower than you could get
if you're only allowed
to rotate blocks 90 degrees.
I don't think the problem
states that explicitly, but this
isn't a trigonometry class, so
I think we're in good shape.
OK.
Right.
So that's our
basic problem here.
And this is one of
these problems that
is going to be a dynamic
programming problem,
but, again, similar to
many of the things that we
saw in lecture, is not
totally obvious how,
because somehow she has
this big, disorganized bag
of blocks.
You could imagine
a universe where
there's 2 to the n different
things she could do, right?
For every single
block, she could
decide whether or not
to put it in her stack,
and then she has to do
a bunch of other work
to verify whether
she can stack them
while supporting the strict
support condition or not.
So, initially, that
seems kind of annoying.
So what we have to
do, which, again,
is pretty common to a
lot of these problems,
is place some order on it.
I mean that both in
the entropy sense,
and also, like, literally,
were going to order stuff.
And, in particular, we'll
see that this problem has
a lot in common
with that longest
common subsequence problem that
we saw in lecture-- increasing
subsequence, sorry.
Right.
So here's some observations
about our problem
which are going to help.
First of all, when
we stack our blocks,
we might as well always align
the shorter side of the block
on top to the shorter side
of the block underneath it.
Right?
Let me draw a picture
of what I mean.
So let's say I have a really--
a block whose base
kind of looks like that
and then another block
which is also rectangular
that I sit on top
of it like that.
Then notice I could-- so in this
case, the shorter edge of one
block is aligned to the
longer edge of the other.
Notice I can rotate
it 90 degrees and it
still supports on one another.
So there's never a case--
you convince yourself with
just a few inequalities--
where I don't, kind of, always
put the long side parallel
to the long side of the guy
underneath and the short side
parallel to the short
guy underneath it.
Does that makes sense?
Cool.
So that's observation one.
Observation two, can
they ever-- like,
let's say that Maggie
actually-- sorry,
Saggy actually had not just
three blocks of a type,
but like 25.
So she's just has hella blocks.
My question is does it matter.
The answer is no because this
word here is really critical,
which is that there's
strict support.
So your block only
has so many faces.
And, in fact, by
observation one,
really all that matters is which
of the three types of faces
is sitting on top because we
can just always rotate it.
So there's three configurations
of every block, so, at most,
can any one configuration
appear more than one time?
No, because of the
strict support condition.
Right?
Otherwise, the rectangles
would match up,
and that's against the rules.
So, in particular-- oops,
the number after two is--
the number after 1 is 2,
which looks like that.
OK.
Right.
So, in particular, there
are only three orientations.
This is just which of the
three edges of the block
is the one that's going away
from the floor, the normal
to the ground.
And moreover, each can appear
less than or equal to 1 time.
That's good because it limits
the size of our problem.
And, finally-- oops, I collapsed
two of the cases in my notes
into one case here.
But that's OK.
And, in fact, notice
that the problem tells us
that she has at least
three of each type.
So, in a sense, if the problem--
if you observe one of a
block you might as well just
throw away the rest
because you know that you
can use it at most three times.
And she has three of that block.
We can't use it more than
three times, so in a sense,
that's just superfluous
information.
OK.
Right.
So this allows us to put
a little bit of order
here, because notice that when
I look at the stack of blocks
here, what do we know?
If I look at the
length of the long side
and the length of the short
side in the plane of the ground,
those numbers have to decrease
on every level of my block.
They can never increase.
That's what the strict
support conditions says,
combined with observation
one, actually, even
without observation one,
which is good news, right?
So this is what's going to
allow us to impose order
on our problem, namely, that
we can sort by the edge lengths
because we know that we
have this support condition.
OK.
So let's fill in some
details of our algorithm.
OK.
So originally-- already we can
see that our list of blocks
is kind of useless
because the width, length,
and values are sorted in
ways that don't matter.
Moreover, if we have more
than three of a given block,
that's somehow not super useful.
So, instead of that,
without loss of generality,
let's assume--
so WLOG here-- we can always
take our block and assume--
I'm going to do this slightly
different from my notes--
that the width is less than
or equal to the height is less
than or equal to the length.
OK.
So every block, if
this isn't the case,
I could go down my array
of blocks and sort.
And sorting a list of three
numbers is constant time.
OK?
Right.
So what does this
allow me to do?
Well, I'm going to say
that a block type actually
is an ordered set where
the third number is going
to be the axis that points up.
And the reason to
do that is that we
know that we can never
use that more than once
for any type of a block.
Yeah?
So now I'm going to make a new
list of blocks with a capital B
because I like blocks.
And it's going to look
like the following.
So if width-- so if w is
less than h is less than l,
then I'm going to
take every block
and duplicate it three times.
Notice that I might end up
with a list with, like, nine
times of every block,
but we'll fix that later.
Right.
And it's going to look
like the following, which
is that, OK, I'm going
to have wi, hi, li.
This is like describing a way
to stack my block because it's
saying this is the short
side, this is the long side,
this is the vertical side.
And there are three cases
where any one of these guys
can be the vertical side.
So there's one.
Let's say that the h
is the vertical side,
then w has to go before l.
So it would be wi, li,
hi, and a third one
where the third guy is w.
H is less than l, so
it would be hi, li, wi.
And those are all
the different ways
that I can, sort of, orient
these blocks in my stacking,
assuming that I impose condition
one for convenience here.
OK.
I'm going to make a
new list of blocks
where I take every
block in my original set
and I just duplicate
it three times this way
after I sort its coordinates.
And now, well, what
do I need to do?
For one thing, this thing
may have too many blocks.
I might have a block that's
repeated more than one time
and I can't do that.
And moreover, it's going
to be convenient to have
this sorted because I've got
to stack these guys eventually.
Yeah?
So I'm going to sort that list.
And I want to do it--
I can never say this
word-- lexicographically,
meaning that I'm going sort out
the first coordinate, and then
the second and the
third lexicographically.
Notice this length is 3 n if
I had n blocks to start with.
So this entire thing takes
order n log n time, which
is important to account for.
And then I can
remove duplicates.
I'll let you guys
convince yourself
you can do this in order n time.
An easier way would've been
making second array and just
kind of move--
and only add stuff
when you didn't
see the same thing before.
OK.
And, finally, now these are
ordered in a really nice way
because I can stack
my blocks, but only
ever looking to the
right in my sorted
list, assuming that I'm stacking
from the top of my tower down,
which is, I think, sort of
what's going on in this thing.
OK.
So now, finally, we
can do our SRTBOT.
And I might do S and R
and T and then allow you
guys to think about the
rest because, as usual,
I'm talking too much.
OK.
So now this is starting to
look like a subsequence problem
because, essentially, when
I stuck my blocks, if I
use this block here--
again, if I'm stacking from
my tower from the top down--
all the blocks that can
sit underneath this one
have to be further to the right
in my array because of the way
that I sorted.
Now, that doesn't mean
that I can put anything
on the right
underneath this guy,
but it does mean that I
know nothing to the left
can go underneath this guy.
That's the way to
think about it.
OK.
So it is going to be SRTBOT.
So S, what I'm going
to say is that x i here
is equal to the maximum height
of my tower, and I'm going to--
taking a little
bit of inspiration
from our subsequence problem
that we've already seen,
I'm going to force
myself to use block i.
We'll see if that's convenient.
i and possibly-- just
for fun, maybe we'll
do the prefix version of
this problem this time.
So now I can use any
of the previous blocks.
So I can use the first i
blocks to make a tower,
but I'm forced to use block i.
By the way, from now
on, when I use indices,
it's into this sorted array.
OK.
So this is a problem.
Obviously, if I
could solve for x,
I would be done, because I
could get the maximum height
by just iterating over all the
x's and choosing the biggest
possible value here.
And the question is, how
do I do this recursively?
OK.
So here's our recursive step.
So let's say that I
use block i, well,
because we know we have to.
Right?
So, in particular, we have--
now I'm seeing why they
didn't use this notation
in their answer, but that's OK.
Let's use another letter to
refer to the third coordinate.
AUDIENCE: v i for
vertical [INAUDIBLE]..
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Yeah,
let's say v i is always
the third coordinate.
We've already used
w, h, and l, and I'm
afraid if I reuse
them after sorting,
it's going to confuse people.
So v i is the third
coordinate of the i-th element
of my sorted array.
That's fine, OK.
Right, so what is my
height if I use x i here?
Well, I get some height from vi.
And in addition to
that, I get whatever
I stack underneath that guy.
So, in particular,
I get that xi.
Well, I get the
height of the block
that I just decided to use.
And now, what are all my cases?
Well, I could decide
to do nothing else,
like, just not use
any other blocks.
That gives me a height of 0.
Or, well, let's see here.
I could use the x's,
but I have to be careful
that I can actually stack them.
So, in particular,
well, I need--
yeah, I can take an
x j value, but I've
got to be careful that I
can stick it underneath.
So, in particular,
what do we know?
Well, I can do anything
from 1 to i minus 1
because that's sort of
the definition of xi.
But, in particular, I
can stack it on top.
So one easy way to do
this is I just array--
I iterate through the first i
minus 1 elements of my array,
and I just check my
stacking condition
for every single
one of them relative
to block j, so, in other words,
that the width and the height--
or rather, the first and
the second coordinate
satisfy the strict
inequalities that I need.
I'm phrasing this
sentence neutrally
because I forget whether this
is increasing or decreasing.
But in any event--
so what do I do?
I check all of the blocks
that I could possibly
stack from the index of
the array perspective.
I make sure that I could
actually stack them,
thanks to the size
of the current block
that I just decided
to add to my stack.
And I move recursively.
OK.
Right.
So this is great
because now we're
in exactly the recursive
scenario we wanted
to be in, because x i
only depends on x j, where
j is smaller than i.
And that is exactly
our topological
ordering that we need.
If you do that on your homework,
you get a minus n for large n.
OK.
Similarly, what's our base case?
Well, obviously, if I
only have one block,
I might as well use it.
So in that case, we have x1 is
equal to v(1) our notation here
like that.
Our original one, we have to
be a little bit careful because
of the way that I've defined
x, because x assumes that I've
used a particular
block, so I have to say,
well, I might not have actually
chosen the very last block
as the one I want to keep.
So I have to iterate.
I can say that,
really, my original
is the max over i of x i.
So one of these blocks has
to be the block on top.
I'm just going to iterate
over all the possible ones
and find it.
And then our final thing
to do is the runtime t.
This one is mildly trickier
than the previous runtimes
that we've done so far
in our example problem.
In particular, how many
subproblems are there?
Well, there's n subproblems--
or I'll say order n because
I'm always off by 1--
corresponding to each
block in my stack here.
But how much time
does each subproblem
take, at least the way
that I've written it here?
Well, what I have to do?
I have to loop over all
of the possible blocks
and find the one that
I can stack on top of
and then take the max.
So there's a loop here from 1
to i. i is upper bounded by n.
So this is order n
subproblems times order n
work per subproblem.
So at the end of the
day, my algorithm
is going to be order
n squared time.
And, of course, again--
I guess I promised it and
then I didn't actually do it--
to actually implement
this algorithm,
there's sort of two
different ways to do it.
I could write a recursive
call plus a table.
The tables maybe initialized
to a bunch of NaNs.
And then I implement this
function recursively.
But before I do that, I say, if
the table does not equal NaN,
just return the
value in the table
and otherwise call
this recursion.
Or I can just have a
four loop from 1 to n
and build up the table
one element at a time.
And both of those
are exactly the same
from a runtime perspective.
OK.
So I think I've managed
to watch that much
more than my notes or
the written solution,
but the problem
itself is actually
pretty straightforward.
So if you guys read through
the answer plus some of--
I think, actually, the
hard parts of this problem
were not the
dynamic programming,
it was all the observations
you need to get there.
So that's why I spent a
little more time there.
OK.
So, as usual, I haven't
left myself enough time
for the last problem.
But we have a few
minutes and that'll
be sufficient to
set up the parts.
I actually found
the last problem
to be easier even though
it technically is, sort of,
two dynamic programs in one.
So I think the logic
is a little easier.
OK.
So
AUDIENCE: Use the
backboard [INAUDIBLE]..
JUSTIN SOLOMON: I think
this is the backboard.
Yeah, I was just realizing
that this room doesn't work
the same way as the other one.
Yeah, this is embarrassing.
You know, I spent all day
thinking about topology,
and this is like a classic kind
of problem in that universe.
OK.
Well, we'll just erase
one board at a time,
and I'll try not to write
three feet wide this time.
Oh, this is probably the
one board I shouldn't use.
I don't think I
like this classroom.
OK.
So, right, in our final problem,
we're given an n-by-n grid.
And on our n-by-n
grid, Princess Apple--
Banana--
AUDIENCE: Plum.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: --Plum.
Princess Plum.
Right, so here's
our basic setup.
There's a big grid of
stuff, or maybe a small grid
because I don't
feel like drawing.
And every grid square can
have one of three things.
We can have a mushroom.
We can have a tree.
Or it can have nothing at all.
And our princess starts
here, and she goes--
she wants to go there.
And moreover, there's
a couple of things
that are worth noting here.
So, first of all, her
path is quick, meaning
that she can only traverse
2n minus 1 grid squares
to get from one
corner to the other.
And, apparently, she's
very into mushrooms,
and she'd like to accumulate
as many as possible
along her path.
That's the basic setup here.
So she wants to get from the
upper left to lower right.
And, in order to do so, she
wants to take a quick path.
Her main priority
is to be efficient.
But among the
different quick paths,
she wants to pick up
a lot of mushrooms.
It's understandable.
AUDIENCE: And not
walk through trees.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: And not only
through trees, thank you.
So maybe there's
some grid squares
that are marked with a
tree, meaning that you just
can't go there.
That's a tree.
OK.
Right, so that's our
basic setup here.
But the problem does--
it takes a bit of
a twist, right?
It's not saying just could
be the shortest path, which
would be very much like the
last kind of unit in 6.006.
But rather, the
question is, sort of,
what is the number of paths
that she can take from one side
to the other and what is the
maximum number of mushrooms, is
roughly the question
asking, or at least
what I remember from
reading it last night.
AUDIENCE: The number of paths
that maximizes the same number.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: That's right.
So she has to take the
most number of mushrooms
she can, but there may be
more than one path that
gets you there
that is quick, that
satisfies this
condition, in which case,
she wants the count of
the total number of ways
you could get from one
corner to the other.
Why, you might ask--
why not?
OK.
So, right.
So, for instance, maybe
there's a mushroom here.
Now there's a quick
path that gets her there
and collects one mushroom.
So there's exactly one.
But maybe if there's a mushroom
there, well, initially,
it feels like maybe she
could get two mushrooms.
She could go there, go pick
up the second mushroom,
and get back.
But we're going to see that
this quick condition actually
allows-- it doesn't
allow you to do that.
OK?
So, in fact, it'll turn out
that quick paths can only
collect one mushroom
in this 3-by-3 case,
so there's at least
two different paths.
Well, there's 1,
2, 3 different ways
that she could collect one
mushroom and have a quick path.
OK.
So the first thing to
notice is the instructions
are a little bit sneaky
by defining quick paths,
basically, by giving
her no slack at all.
Right?
And here's a basic observation.
Notice that in order to
give from the upper left
to the bottom right,
she's going to have
to go down and to the right.
Plausibly, she could also go up.
She could try and go around
a tree, but only plausibly.
And, in particular, the question
is how many times does she
have to go down and
how many times did she
have to go to the right.
Well, she has to get to
the bottom of the grid.
So she's on grid
square number 1.
She has to go down, in this
case, at least two more
times, so, in general,
n minus 1 times.
She has to go to the
right n minus 1 times.
So what does that mean?
She has to make
2n minus 2 moves.
And that's a lower bound, right?
So if she goes up, she's going
to have to go down again,
so it's only going
to make it bigger.
Right?
So at the very least, she
has to do 2n minus 2 moves
down and right to get from the
upper left to the lower right.
How many squares does she
touch when she's doing that?
This is a fence post problem.
So she made 2n minus
2 moves, and she
had a place where she started.
That implies that just by
moving down and to the right,
she makes 2n minus 1 squares--
she touches, rather.
So can she ever move up?
No.
Can she ever move to the left?
And that, basically, is all
you need to solve this problem.
The rest of it's
actually pretty easy.
So the basic observation here
is she can only move down
and to the right because if
she moved up or to the left,
her path would no
longer be called quick,
and that would be a problem.
Moreover, every path that
moves down and to the right
is a quick path, assuming
she reaches their target
and doesn't hit a tree.
OK?
So that's the basic observation.
And notice that that
already basically suggests--
it's, like, screaming
out to you--
how to do dynamic programming
because, literally, you have
a table looking at you on
the blackboard right now,
and you have an ordering
down and to the right that
is acyclic.
Yeah?
OK.
Have I slammed on the
board enough times?
The first time I
taught at Stanford,
I got negative course feedback
that I had too much coffee
and was slamming on the
board a lot, apparently.
I watched the video later, and,
indeed, that was not wrong.
OK.
So, right.
So, we're going to call k--
this is going to be
the max mushrooms she
can get going on the entire
path from the upper left
of the lower right.
So we want to know the
number of quick paths
that can achieve this number k.
OK.
So let's do SRTBOT really fast
because I've got four minutes--
actually, a tiny bit more than
that because we started late.
OK.
Now, the kind of
annoyance here is
that there's two different
numbers that we don't know.
One of them is k, and the
other is the number of paths.
The problem didn't tell you how
many mushrooms she can pick up.
It does tell you that
there's some path
to get from the upper
left to the bottom right,
that there's not just
like a row of trees
somewhere, which I feel
in my commute sometimes.
But it doesn't
tell you the number
that she has to accomplish.
And, initially, that's
kind of annoying.
So maybe the first
thing that we do
is just compute k,
like, the maximum number
of mushrooms that she can
collect on any quick path.
And then we go back and
compute that other count.
That would be one
problem-solving approach
that we could think
about a little bit.
So, in particular, let's define
our k ij to be equal to--
well, we can generalize
our problem slightly,
and say what is the
number of mushrooms
that I can get on any kind
of rectangle embedded inside
of my full problem, right?
So, in other words, this is
the max number of mushrooms,
or m's for short, on
a quick path to ij.
So, in other words, she always
starts in the upper left,
but now she stops at
any other grid cell.
OK?
Because I'm running
low on time--
no, I'm going to do this
the way I want to do this.
No, so we're just
going to think about k.
Yeah?
So the question is
could we compute just
as value k, which
certainly seems convenient.
Princess Plum, she might
as well know her enemy.
She might as well know
the number of mushrooms
she's targeting,
if she can get it.
So how could we do
this recursively?
Well, she has to
get to position ij.
And from our argument
up there, she
has to get there by either
coming from up or to the left,
the way we've chosen to
write down this problem.
So what are our different cases?
Well, first of all,
if there's a tree,
you can't do a damn thing.
She shouldn't even
be able to get there.
And for convenience,
we're going to find
you can argue that it's 0.
We're going to mark this
with a special number,
and we'll see that
that makes our notation
a little convenient.
So one is if there
exists a tree,
then we're going to say
k ij is minus infinity.
Again, there's a
philosophical question there.
Does she get minus
infinity mushrooms
if she is standing
on top of a tree?
I don't know,
because she shouldn't
stand on top of a tree.
But at least it's going to
let us know that something
went wrong in this grid
square in the other parts
of our recursion.
OK?
And otherwise, well, what
are our different cases here?
Well, she always picks up
a mushroom if it's there.
She might as well.
She's maximizing.
In fact, the problem even
says that she's really
into mushrooms.
She collects them
automatically, right?
So what do we get?
I use unnecessarily
fancy notation.
This is an indicator of
whether there exists a mushroom
at position ij, meaning
this is a 1 if there is,
and there's a 0 if there's not.
Sometimes this is indicated with
a 1 with a little subscript,
but whatever.
In addition to that,
she might have picked up
mushrooms along paths.
And we know that her path
to position ij either
came from up or to the left.
So, in other words,
we know that she
could have gotten the max
from any path ending above her
or any path to the left of her.
So that's k i minus
1j, which, I guess,
is to the left, and k
ij minus 1, like that.
And this can be used to fill
in our whole table of k values.
In fact, since I'm
low on time, I'll
let you do the TBOT for the
remainder of this problem.
Essentially, I think the
key observation is this one.
Obviously, when she
starts in the upper left,
she gets 0 mushrooms
because she's not
standing on top of one.
The problem says that.
And this allows us to
fill in our whole table k.
So, in particular, this
gives us our enemy now.
We now know how many
mushrooms she should have
at every step of her journey.
In fact, it tells
us a tiny bit more
than that because it
says if I'm at this grid
sq-- at this particular
grid square during my path,
I should have this
many mushrooms.
If I didn't, then
something went wrong.
Yeah?
So the way that the
solution is written,
they do two pieces of
the recursion at once.
You actually could have just
solved for this k matrix
first and then gone back
and done the second half
of this problem.
And those are exactly the same.
And when I was
writing my solution,
this is the way I thought
about it, because, somehow, I
kind of felt like she
might as well know
how many mushrooms she wants
to collect before she starts
counting paths.
That's like a secondary
question, you know.
And so this is one way to do it.
So in our remaining
negative 2 minutes,
let's think about the
recursion for computing.
Remember that we want to know
the number of paths needed
to collect that many
mushrooms, the maximum number
of mushrooms.
Please let there not be a whole
lot of stuff on this board.
Ah, there's not any
stuff on this board.
That's great.
OK.
So, in particular, now I'm
going to define a second thing
that I also I'm going to
do dynamic programming on.
I'm going to say that x ij
is equal to-- and I'm going
to make it kind of a
sneaky definition here,
which is the number of quick
paths that end at ij with--
now, let's anticipate
our problem a little bit.
So at the end of the day, we're
going to do x of n comma n
because she wants to end up all
the way down and to the right.
And how many mushrooms
does she want to have,
now that we know k?
She wants to have k of
n comma n mushrooms.
Along the way, it would
be kind of ambitious
if she wanted to
have k of n comma n
mushrooms the entire path.
But it would be slightly
less ambitious to have
k of ij mushrooms
because, somehow, that's
exactly what we just constructed
in the previous thing
where it was paths.
Well, the last guy
looks like a max.
Now we're going to expect
to see some plus signs here
because we're adding up
how many paths we have.
OK?
And now let's come up with a
recursive rule for the array x,
and then we'll call it a day.
So, in particular, [INAUDIBLE]
one, if there's a tree,
how many paths are there?
There are no paths,
because I can't get there.
So then ij equals 0.
OK?
Otherwise, there ain't a tree.
And now I have to be a
little careful, right?
So I need to write this
like a little piece of code.
You could have written this as
a giant max, instead, or a bunch
of cases and whatever.
So let's think about it
like a piece of code.
So, initially, I think
there are no paths that
get me k ij mushrooms.
That's perfectly fine.
And remember,
we're going to keep
applying the same
piece of logic,
which is that a path can only
come from to the left and up.
And let's think about
those two cases.
And by the way, we're
going to use chi
to equal this chi
of stuff that we
had in the previous expression.
So chi is 1 if there's a
mushroom at this place,
and 0 if there is not.
OK.
So my path can come
from the left or up.
I know that it can't come from
up if the number of mushrooms
that I got from up plus,
potentially, the one that I got
here doesn't align with
the number of mushrooms
that I should have
by the k ij standard
that I have set for myself.
So if I want to write that out
in code, the way I do that is I
would say, if k of--
so let's say I look
to the left first.
This is like, you know, look to
your left, look to your right,
one of you will pass this
exam kind of scenario.
And I potentially add a
mushroom at my current position
if there is one.
If that is equal to k ij,
well, what does that mean?
That means that paths
that went to the left
were able to collect the number
of mushrooms I need to get
to the position I am now.
So now I can add all
of the different ways.
Maybe I'll do a plus
equals x of i minus 1j
because any path that
got to the previous guy
and collected the right
number of mushrooms
can now reach me and get the
right number of mushrooms.
And similarly, I can look up
and do exactly the same logic.
So if k of ij minus 1 plus
this number is equal to k ij,
then x ij gets an additional
number of paths, like that.
And now I do think it's worth
spending 8 seconds thinking
about our base cases
here because, initially,
when I first saw this,
I panicked a little bit
because it kind of looks
like this would just end up
getting a bunch of 0's
because I'm just adding
values of x's to themselves.
I don't have, like,
a 1 plus anything
anywhere, which is kind of
weird if you think about it.
So all of the reason why
the positive numbers appear
in this problem is from the base
case, which is kind of cool,
I think.
This is like, I think,
one of these things where
if you anticipated a
problem, then it's cool,
and if you didn't anticipate
the problem to begin with
and you just wrote
down these formulas,
you probably wouldn't even
think that it's interesting.
But in any event,
what is our base case?
So, we'll do the B in SRTBOT.
So, first of all,
what is k of 1, 1?
Remember, that's the
number of mushrooms
she can collect by
starting at the left square
and going nowhere.
And that's 0 because
the problem says there's
no mushrooms in the upper left.
What's x of 1, 1?
Well, this is the
number of paths from 1,
1 to itself that collects
0 mushrooms, so that's 1.
OK.
And I think that the
rest of the SRTBOT table
here isn't terribly
difficult to fill in.
So I noticed that in
kind of a funny way,
all of these recursive
steps are just adding 1
to itself a bunch of times.
But, of course, the way
you do that, the reason why
you get a number
that is interesting,
is because of all these
if statements and the fact
that you can add two
different pluses coming
from two different sources.
OK.
So I actually do
encourage you guys
to look at the code in
the problem solution
because I think it's a
nice example of taking
this recursive formula and
then unrolling it into,
like, iterating over a table.
And that's a useful skill
that I intended to do today
and then didn't actually
do very carefully.
But with that, as usual,
we've gone over time here.
So we'll call it for the day.
And I will see you guys
when I see you guys.
All right.